to break this down for us Vlad journeyed
across the studio to speak with our
elections and surveys director Anthony
salvanto Vlad what's going on not a long
journey Nate but Anthony's here so we're
feeling good all right so let's talk
about the races that we're still
watching this morning that are too close
to calling all right let's start in
Georgia What's Left not a lot 96 percent
in where is it okay we got red areas
here those are Republican blue counties
over there around Metro Atlanta I'm
going to show you where the remaining
vote is I'm going to turn the state on
its side the higher bars mean more
outstanding vote it is around Atlanta
that could favor Warnock when it comes
in but we'll see if anybody gets over 50
percent next I'm going to go up to
Wisconsin okay and I'm going to show you
Mandela Barnes is narrowly trailing but
here again where is the outstanding vote
I'm going to turn this on its side
you'll see the bar pop up around
Milwaukee that's the one County where
Barnes could do really well so still too
close to say next I'm going to take out
I'm going to go to Arizona this one
markelli does have a lead but still
substantial number out right so you have
it leaning down we do have it leaning
down because Dan because he's got that
lead and then finally Vlad I'm gonna go
and we're gonna go out to Nevada here
we've got Captain Cortez Master down to
Adam Waxhaw I'm gonna turn this one
inside and it's all about Las Vegas all
right it's all about Las Vegas you can
see that pop up so still a lot of vote
out there I don't know if it's early
vote I don't know if it's election day
Republicans tend to do better on
Election Day so when we find that out
we'll be able to say more about the race
all right so Anthony uh we know all
throughout this election cycle
Republicans have been predicting a red
wave but Lindsey Graham last night said
definitely not a wave so where did
Republicans go wrong okay let's look at
where we are in the house estimate right
now Republicans still have a lead it's
still leaning towards the Republicans
they could still get over 218 a lot of
toss-ups out there there's still at
least 15 toss-up races that we haven't
projected yet so that remains to be seen
I think this is going to take a few days
but you can take a few days to sort out
so 203 to 190 is our latest house system
so you know I was with the exit poll
Team all night last night and one of the
things that we found that was really
interesting is independent voters they
were breaking for Republicans before
October since October breaking for
Democrats Democrats did well with
Independence last night and you see
abortion was a close second to inflation
in the economy on the minds of Voters we
talked all the time about the restoring
Roe voters the women who made abortion
and abortion rights a priority they
moved even more towards the Democrats
that helped them too all right Anthony
salvanto thank you my friend